-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers,
and this is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well.
And now we are going to
get to the news.
According to ex-White House
press secretary
Stephanie Grisham's new book,
former president Trump
was once asked to go
vegan for charity,
but if you didn't lose him
at "vegan,"
I'm sure you lost him
at "charity."
In the same book, former
Trump administration staffer
Stephanie Grisham
describes The White House as
"A clown car on fire
running at full speed
into a warehouse
full of fireworks."
But she apparently
doesn't mention
the part where
she called "Shotgun!"
Former President Trump,
last week, called in to a
prophecy-focused conservative
Christian talk show and said
"Nobody has done more for
Christianity or for Evangelicals
or for religion itself
than I have."
Really? Nobody?
You can't think of
a single person?
Jesus Christ.
Former President Trump
reportedly tells people
constantly that he is running
for president in 2024.
Well, he doesn't tell everyone.
[ As Trump ]
It's your year, Mike.
After postponing
last week's vote on
the bipartisan
infrastructure package,
House Speaker Nancy Pelosi,
on Saturday,
set a new Halloween deadline,
because nothing is spookier
to Democrats than actually
passing legislation.
According to a recent survey,
10% of Americans said
that they feel very pessimistic
about the rest of 2021,
while the other 90% said,
"It's 2021?"
Clint Eastwood, on Friday,
won a $6 million lawsuit
against a Lithuanian company
that used his image
to promote CBD products.
I'm not sure how
they used his image,
but I'm guessing as "before"?
Passengers on
a Spirit Airlines plane in
Atlantic City, New Jersey,
were forced to deplane
over the weekend after a large
bird caused an engine fire.
And this is sad -- that bird
still had a better time
than everyone who spent
the weekend in Atlantic City.
According to a new book,
former First Lady Melania Trump
obsessively read
her own press coverage,
because you can
only re-read your
marriage contract so many times.
And, finally,
according to a new survey,
42% of Americans
said that they feel bad
if they don't do
anything productive all day.
Fortunately, clicking
this counts as productive.
And that was a monologue.